president Bollinger on behalf of the
Dean and the Faculty of the food
Foundation School of Engineering and
Applied Science and the class of 2010 I
respectfully ask your permission to
start these ceremonies with that
permission I shall begin president
Bollinger Dean pin amaura Provost steel
dr. brandt ralph honored participants
distinguished faculty alumni and guests
i'm proud to recognize the members of
the class of 2010 and marked their
shared and individual accomplishments it
is now my honor to present to you the
salutatorian for the Columbia
engineering class of 2010 Rodney Chang
I once heard that having a reason to
live in a limited time to live it is
what makes life worth living though the
source may be questionable at best the
quote itself makes perfect sense most of
us choose to attend Columbia because we
aspire to better ourselves
it's our reason to be here the second
part the quote a time limit is more
difficult to appreciate after all
working on a project hours before the
deadline is no pleasant experience
however if you looked at however if we
look back at our undergraduate years and
judge it as a whole which had find that
our stay at columbia was an amazing
experience
add to that sentiment our limited time
and we should value our memories as
students more unfortunately the nature
of the academic year conspires against
us after one semester ends another soon
begins student life is a seemingly
endless cycle of homeworks exams
part-time employment and of course time
with friends we don't have time to think
about our past
besides y-value memories we will relive
next semester things change during our
senior year the end is approaching when
the prospects of finding a job sets in
as it should have by now we begin
thinking or panicking about our future
again the pass has pushed it back of our
minds it should not stay there
our memories are a repository of
knowledge in a valuable reference to our
present selves in hindsight we should
realize columbia is very much like the
subways that run underneath it it
provides an infinite number of places to
take our academic economic and social
lives it's a great crossroads but unlike
many are we are sure to encounter later
in life there's no lack of guidance
personally I doubt I will ever encounter
another crossroads like Columbia and I'm
forever grateful to the faculty and
staff for the opportunities and advice
they offered me
I would especially like to thank
professor Modi professor stole fee and
the mechanical engineering department
for the continued support during my
undergraduate years it's also rarely
empty there's no lack of companionship
whether this studying for finals or
going out to movies friends live only
blocks from each other and in many cases
in the same dorm or suite classes
assigned not just homeworks but projects
that require frequent collaboration
among members for me the most memorable
project was senior design it provided me
with the opportunity to work with the
computer science department and other
students of the same major but with
different specialties it was by no
measure an easy project but working all
night was made bearable by the simple
fact that my classmates were sitting at
the adjacent computers despite the
hardships that often accompany it
opportunity is a wonderful feeling of
freedom learn to recognize and cherish
it looking back we should also realise
how far we have progressed since
entering college the fact that we are
sitting here today is enough evidence
but consider for an instance that it is
not think about the real-world
applications of everything you've
learned for mechanical engineers I ask
what do you have been able to design a
gear transmission determine safety
factors and modeled and CAD during your
freshman year for any parent the past
four years may seem to be a short time
in fact it may only seem like yesterday
when your children were moving into
dorms in some ways four years is a short
time but for us it's a lot four years is
nearly a fifth of our current life more
importantly it's a time for us to
transform from freeloaders into
independent adults
in these four years I hope we've made
you proud
thank you for your unwavering support we
wouldn't be here without you soon many
of us will take jobs and enter the real
world others will continue on to further
education regardless of our paths new
challenges await us to this I have only
one piece of advice of advice you
probably heard many times work hard and
you'll go far but before that enjoy
graduation you've earned it
Thank You Rodney
it's now my distinct honor and pleasure
to introduce Phineas keep any Maura Dean
of the Foo Foundation School of
Engineering and Applied Science and then
the more si and Alma Shapiro professor
of engineering he is also a professor of
civil engineering and engineering
mechanics earth and environmental
engineering and of computer science at
Columbia University Dean Panamera came
to Columbia in July of 2009 from the
University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign where he served as
associate provost for the past year we
have all been privileged to enjoy his
leadership and to see his great vision
for Columbia engineering unfold in so
many ways please join me in welcoming
Dean penny Morra
thank you Kevin welcome and
congratulations to the class of 2010 I'm
very proud to be in front of you today
in my first class day as Dean of
Columbia engineering since you are the
ones that will develop everything useful
for the comfort the convenience and the
elegance of life one of the charges of
the original mission of Columbia set
forth in 1754 but first I will ask all
the graduates to stand please look to
where your parents are I know you're
going to be looking all directions look
at your family your loved ones and thank
them in any way you feel is appropriate
applauding waving cheering shouting
bowing or silent tear don't sit down yet
now look forward no at me but at the
faculty who have instruct you make sure
you and help you reach the place where
you are today
now please sit down it is my great
pleasure to introduce Columbia
University President Lee Bollinger who's
shaping Colombia for future generations
a distinguished First Amendment legal
scholar and a passionate advocate of
access to higher education for students
from all backgrounds whose farts Agnes
has set the path for the university's
growth for the coming decades his
inspired vision for Manhattanville
includes the internship Ranieri mind
brain and behavior building and research
facility for the future of science while
the global centers he has established
around the world serves as academic and
research hubs from which columbia
scholarship will radiate he has brought
to the forefront the importance of
science applied science technology and
engineering while continuing to champion
the fine arts and the liberal arts in
noble and substantial ways he embodies
the attributes that you all possess as
grader of our great school he is a
socially responsible leader whose work
provides for the betterment of the human
condition locally nationally and
globally please join me in welcoming
President Lee Bollinger
thank you very much since I have your
undivided attention on Tuesday along
with 11,000 other graduates of the class
of 2010 I will be very brief today I
just want to say these a couple things
finneus keep in amaura is a new dean
here and has worked extremely hard on
behalf of seas and the university and
I'd like to express our gratitude to him
and I know you would as well thank you
very much
you're a wonderful class you have come
from all over the world you are deeply
committed to public service the New York
Times article on public service here
noted the programs that you engage in
that is a great benefit to the people
that you've served in our communities
but it's a great benefit to Columbia as
well and I want to thank you for that
the main thing I want to say to you
is that as I think about all of the
problems and all of the potential that
the world has at this point whether it's
about climate change or about poverty or
about disease or about censorship and
how to deal with it it is what you have
been educated in that makes it possible
to solve these so much of what we have
today in the way of the benefits of
modern life come from the professions in
which you've been educated and what will
help to make them even better what will
make humanity better and the world
better is the discoveries are the
discoveries that you can contribute to
over time and on behalf of the
University I want to say it's both your
responsibility and your privilege to be
part of the solutions to those great
problems so on behalf of the University
again congratulations to the class of
Thank You president Bollinger I now like
to introduce the senior fund Committee
choke co-chairs Liza John and Ann Quay
before we begin we would like to ask the
members of the 2010 senior fund
committee to please stand
senior fun this year was exciting for
multiple reasons beyond the fantastic
commitment and dedication of the
committee and simply the best
engineering class at Columbia thus far
this was this was year this this year
was Dean penny Maura's first year as the
Dean of the food foundation School of
Engineering and Applied Science we
wanted to end his first year and our
last year on a high note and so we began
with very ambitious senior fun goals
raising five thousand dollars the
highest monetary goal of any class so
far and reaching a hundred percent
participation from the class of 2010
this ambition is not arbitrary and it's
not sudden it's well cultivated from
years of Columbia education that has
instilled within us a drive for bigger
and better in the last four years we
grew up here in New York City where we
developed an independent attitude a
combination of challenges and ability
and a passion that feeds our unendingly
long list of goals we are not afraid of
today or tomorrow because we are trained
as Columbia engineers therefore when we
discuss their goals at the beginning of
the year for senior fund the committee
wasn't afraid to take on the challenge
of setting the highest monetary goal and
participation in senior fund history we
knew that the spirited and dedicated
class of 2010 had our backs and we were
confident that we could present to seize
and Dean penny more the best
representation of our love and
appreciation for our alma mater on
behalf of the senior fund committee and
class of 2010 Dean Penner Mora we
proudly present you the squirrel on it
is the full list of every senior who has
participated in our class gift from the
bottom of our hearts we hope you've had
a wonderful first year at Columbia and
may this gift be the ultimate icing on
the cake
Hey
did we reach our goal
without fail Columbia Engineers pulled
through again to raise five thousand two
hundred and seventy-six dollars and five
cents with eighty eight percent
participation beyond this we secured a
matching gift of $10,000 from a recent
C's alumna we are proud to present to
Dean penny more a total gift of fifteen
thousand dollars two hundred and seventy
six dollars and five cents yeah the the
largest and senior class gift history at
Columbia engineering the gift will go
directly toward improving the Columbia
experience for future generations of C's
students class of 2010 we thank you for
your friendship your camaraderie and
your support has been a wonderful four
years without a doubt you're the purest
example of proud capable of Columbia
engineers thank you and happy graduation
Thank You class of 2010
in special thank you to you and Lisa and
to the entire senior fun class gift
committee I'm honored to asset this
scroll with your names on behalf of the
current and future see students who will
benefit from your contributions to your
school thank you for the participation
and your leadership
president Bollinger Provost Steele the
intial and Burger King brand roof
members of the faculty on our guests
Aluna parents family members and those
whose accomplishments we celebrate today
members of the Seas graduating class of
2010 today is an amazing day for all of
us for some of you it has been four
years of undergraduate study for others
those of you who are combined plan
students it has been two years and four
masters and PhD and four masters and PhD
students this is the end of a program
that began anywhere from one to five or
six years ago no matter how long you
have been here the ceremonies today and
Tuesday will remain in your memories for
a lifetime I know that you will always
remember what your Columbia Education
has been all about excellence leadership
and impact and where this education has
taken place the Columbia community when
you were admitted to this school you
were already among the very best
students in the world
you possess innate qualities of
excellence that our school has continued
to nurture to borrow an analogy you
yourself are one of the most exquisite
gems waiting to be set in Columbia's
crown our part has been to work with you
to help you determine your place in that
crown to enhance what you possess when
you came to us to increase your
knowledge and in doing so to enhance
your excellence but excellence by itself
is not enough think about an input and
output diagram the input is your
excellence that Columbia engineering has
nurtured during your time here but now
you have to do something with that
excellence
think about the box between the input
and output that's what I consider
leadership
you must take what you know and rise and
use it in a meaningful manner you have
to identify opportunities or better
still create opportunities
and this is where leadership comes in
you were leaders when you enter this
school and we had reinforced your
natural abilities to help you become
even more successful as leaders when you
use your leadership to change the world
and to do it in a socially responsible
way this results in the output impact I
know that the impact of your work we has
been made possible by your excellence
and leadership will resort in the
betterment of the human condition
locally nationally and globally you will
be the ones whose work will solve global
problems of health for the body or
demand sustainability that might be in
water energy or in climate
infrastructure that whether is physical
or DITA information whether theory or
application or system whether open or
closed some of you will choose to make
an impact by bringing together your
knowledge and leadership in pan
disciplinary research perhaps in an area
such as the one that I call cyber
biophysical systems whether biological
physical and digital worlds intersect
and fuse areas which bring together our
knowledge of sensors materials
nanotechnology and biological systems
this is will be one of the frontiers
where some of you will develop
innovative solutions to the most
challenging problems of modern society
others of you will follow a different
path and make your own mark in an area
that is new to us when you first came to
Columbia you may have heard about famous
alumni from the very beginning of King's
College whose work change how people
lived during that time period alumni
whose work make significant societal
advances engineering leaders like John
Stevens who invented a steamboat William
Barclay persons who saw a line the
Broadway line runs adjacent to our
campus or micro pooping who died below
the transatlantic underseas telegraph
cable or edwin angstrom who
revolutionize modern radio
communications science such as Joseph
again Berger often called the father of
robotics or Alma Gaiden
often called the father of biochemical
engineering and business leaders such as
jim alba president of Boeing Commercial
Airplanes or all sulla burns CEO of
Xerox and Vikram Pandit CEO of Citigroup
and arming our nation's a managing
director of Goldman Sachs or maybe you
will leave air all together to make your
impact in space like our alumni NASA
astronauts Mike Massimino and Greg
Johnson the work of those alone eyes
simplifies the legacy of excellence
leadership and impact of Columbia
engineering you are now part of this
legacy and you have the potential to
impact society as dramatically as this
alumni have gone before you
you are the leaders whose work will
provide for the betterment of the human
condition for generations to come and
now let me talk about the larger context
of community to borrow from the words of
the ancient African proverb it takes a
village we are all part of this village
the global village it is this notion of
community that gives all of our values
and our sense of responsibility that
extends outside ourselves our concern
for the sustainability and well-being of
the planet for each other and for future
generations you are part of this larger
global community but also part of the
Columbia community when I first came to
Columbia I read the original mission
written in 1754 when Columbia was
founded as King's College included in
the mission was to teach the arts of
numbers are measuring of surveying and
navigation they knowledge of various
kinds of meteors stones mines and
minerals and everything useful for the
comfort the convenience and elegance of
life how amazing is that
after 256 years our school is still
fulfilling this mission to provide
educate graduates who have learned how
to create everything useful for the
comfort the convenience and the elegance
of life and today in a socially
responsible manner for the betterment of
the human condition locally nationally
and
and in honor of your transition from
students to alumnus or alumna all of New
York will be witness to your excellence
leadership and impact when one of the
nation's greatest landmark the Empire
State Building will light up in Columbia
scholar
or blue and white on Tuesday please make
sure to look up to see this especially
play on commencement 9 and it is with
great pride that I say that it is or it
was a Columbia engineer who make it
happen let's all think Whitney green so
as the newest member of Columbia
engineering alumni community you can now
say to the entire wall you are the gems
in Columbia's crown you are Columbia you
are blue blooded royalty Academy royalty
dairies and you bleed blue Columbia blue
thank you
okay I just trying to find out what I'm
going to do next button now I figured it
out I got my bearings and now on your
behalf the school honors outstanding
faculty members by means of three
separate awards the school bestows they
came award for faculty involvement the
Janet and arming of a nation diversity
Science Award and a Rodriguez junior
faculty development award the school is
critical aware of the importance of the
quality of students life and they need
to foster connections between students
and faculty to help each student achieve
his or her potential there are two
awards given by the school to faculty
members who exhibit exceptional
commitment for a student's academic and
personal growth and achievement the
first award is the Kim award for faculty
involvement established in 2000 by
Edward and Carol Kim parents of Brian
King class of 2001 the Kim's created
this award to honor a faculty member who
is not only an excellent teacher but
also chose a special personal commitment
to students this year winner of the King
award is Professor Lata Venkataraman
assistant professor of the perming of
Applied Physics
professor bank a theramin has been
hailed by one of students as the most
supportive available and involve faculty
member I have worked with and as a very
effective and helpful adviser her impact
on my life has been tremendous roar
another in recognition to dust2 this
achievement let's take again professor
baguette Rahman the second award for
this from the school honors a faculty
member whose actions encourage women and
men from diverse backgrounds to become
part of the academic community of
engineering education believing in the
importance of encouraging young people
from a range of backgrounds the school
Institute this award to recognize those
faculty members whose efforts assist in
this goal University trustee and Bora
visitors chair emeritus arming a
Venetian and his wife Janet who are
personally committed to this effort have
created an endowment to fund this award
in perpetuity the award is given this
year to Professor Solomon Kashani
associate professor in the department
Dawson
professor Kashani was seeded by many
students for his concern for a mentoring
of students from diverse backgrounds
facilitating discussions on diversity
and for cultural sensitivity for both
undergrad and grad students his
apartment has been called Kashani hotel
by the numerous international students
whom he has housed for short periods of
time as they look for permanent
commendations in the Columbia area
thanks ishani the Terr faculty award the
Rodriguez family junior faculty
development award was established by two
alumni of the school Anna Rodriguez
class of 1986 and 1988 and her brother
Marcos Rodriguez in the class of 1983
they have established this award to
support the advancement of junior
faculty in our school the Rodriguez
family junior faculty development award
is given this year to a lone Tyrell
assistant professor in the Department of
Mechanical Engineering
professor Tyrell joined the Department
of Mechanical Engineering mm again and
is pursuing research interests in the
field of thermal fluid sciences focusing
in hydrodynamic lubrication surface
engineering and contact mechanics as
applied to MEMS devices energy system
biomedical devices and sustainable
manufacturing thanks professor Tyrell in
addition to their words instituted by
the school the Columbia engineering
School Alumni Association presents a
work for faculty commitment to teaching
undergraduates at this time it is my
pleasure to introduce the proceeding of
the Columbia nearing Alumni Association
Daniel Cheryl oh dang
dang is a model alumnus he has a long
history of volunteering on behalf of the
school he's a member of the civil
engineering and engineering mechanics
industry Advisory Committee and prior to
taking office as president has served
the Columbia Nehring Alumni Association
as a board member and secretary he is
president and CEO of the stock
engineering international a computer
aided engineering software development
and consulting firm then received his
bachelor's and master's degrees in civil
engineering from Columbia in 1975 and
1976 respectively and has been followed
in the Alumni ranks by one of his
daughters who graduated last year with a
master's degree in civil engineering
please help me welcome dan ciello Thank
You Dean Pena Morra so as he said 35
years ago I attended my own Columbia
engineering class Day ceremony and last
year I attended the same ceremony as a
parent as I watched my daughter graduate
this year on class day I have been given
the honor to be among the first to
congratulate you as president of the
Columbia engineering Alumni Association
affectionately refer to as C EAA as you
may already know all Columbia
engineering graduates are members of C
EAA so on behalf of the 19,000 members
worldwide I would like to say welcome
fellow alumni and congratulations class
of 2010
I could only begin to imagine how
unbelievably proud you are of your
Columbia degree this great
accomplishment was made possible because
of your intellectual curiosity your
remarkable academic personal and
extracurricular achievements your
originality and independence of your
thinking and your diversity that stems
from your different cultures and
educational experiences as a student you
studied very hard I hope for the right
to become an alumnus or alumna of
Columbia University now you will be a
member of the Columbia alumni community
for the rest of your life and the good
news is you will never have to pay any
dues to see EAA in recognition
recognition of a bequest made by CP
Davis a fellow alumnus from the class of
1922 so needless to say you should all
strive to take full advantage of this
incredible lifetime honor just as it was
important to stay involved as students
it is equally important to remain
involved after graduation I hope that
you too will decide to become an active
member of Si EAA and remain an active
part of the Columbia engineering and
Columbia University family the rewards
for doing so are invaluable renew old
friendships and develop new
relationships look around you your
classmates and your professors are and
always will remain a part of your
Columbia family enhance your
professional skills Columbia is a great
place to exchange ideas and it is one of
the greatest universities in the world
to learn and keep abreast of the latest
trends in engineering and other
important topics network with other
alumni this is a great way if not one of
the best ways to help advance your
career and to develop
new business relationships be nostalgic
and create new memories and I promise
whenever you come back to campus you
will always feel like you are coming
home so I hope to see the newest members
of my Columbia family on Dean's day and
Homecoming day speaking to this
outstanding class of engineers today
reminds me of one of my favorite quotes
by Leonardo da Vinci
another great scholar and engineer da
Vinci once said people of accomplishment
rarely sit back and let things happen to
them they go out and happen to things as
proud Columbia scholars engineers and
now Columbia alumni you are people of
accomplishment you are the people that
happened to things so as you commence
this next phase of you of your life we
are all anxious to see the things you
will accomplish and the positive changes
you will make in our world and as you do
so I wish you all the very best of
success and happiness now I'm sure you
all realize that one of the reasons you
are here today is thanks to some of the
well accomplished scholars and engineers
primarily the extraordinary professors
of Columbia University to emphasize this
excellence in teaching and dedication to
undergraduate students the Columbia
engineering Alumni Association
instituted the Columbia distinguished
faculty teaching award C EAA presents
these awards on behalf of students and
alumni to distinguished faculty of
Columbia University's full Foundation
School of Engineering and Applied
Science the award is based on student
evaluations and recommendations of the
selection committee to permanently
recognize the award recipients CEA a
commissioned a plaque to display their
names in carlton lounge one of the
Centers of student activity in the
school each award recipient will
also receive a miniature version of that
plaque along with an honorarium in
appreciation for their caring attitude
and responsiveness to student concerns
and their ability to lucidly teach
essential skills and complex subject
matter the Columbia engineering Alumni
Association takes great pride along with
you the class of 2010 in presenting this
year's distinguished faculty Teaching
Award to Rocco Saverio associate
professor of computer science and Yanis
savita's professor of Electrical
Engineering
dr. savetti Oh holds an AP in
mathematics and a PhD in computer
science from Harvard University as a PhD
student as a PhD student he received a
certificate of distinction in teaching
for three consecutive years and received
the division of Engineering and Applied
Science teaching fellow award in the
year 2000 after finishing his ph.d he
did his postdoctoral work at Harvard
before joining Columbia in 2003
professors of videos research interests
lie in theoretical computer science and
our Center on computational learning
theory and computational complexity
theory he has received the NSF National
Science Foundation Career Award and a
sloan foundation fellowship and his
research is supported by NSF Google and
DARPA the United States Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency
dr. savita's is the Charles Batchelor
professor of Electrical Engineering and
is a previous recipient of the
distinguished faculty Teaching Award
along with many other teaching Awards at
Columbia he received both his MS and PhD
from Berkeley and his BS from the
University of Minnesota
dr. savita's has done extensive work in
analog and mixed-signal integrated
circuits at the device circuit system
and computer simulation level starting
with the first fully fully integrated
metal oxide semiconductor operational
amplifier demonstrated by him in 1976 he
and his students have been responsible
for several contributions ranging from
precision device modeling and novel
circuit building blocks to new
techniques for analog and mixed signal
processing self-correcting chips switch
capacitor network theory and the
creation of computer simulation programs
dr. savita's holds several patents in
several countries he is the recipient of
numerous
outstanding and best paper Awards from
my Tripoli the Institute of Electrical
and Electronics Engineers he is also a
fellow of I Tripoli and received the
Golden Jubilee Golden Jubilee medal from
the I Triple E circuits and system
Society in the year 2000 so with great
appreciation for their enthusiastic
dedication to excellence in teaching our
undergraduates I am proud to present the
2010 distinguished faculty Teaching
Award to Rocco Sir video and Yanis
Severus
Thank You mr. Chappell Oh in each class
there are men and women who distinguish
themselves and their school through
superior academic accomplishments and
service to others over the past few
weeks we have recognized students who
have been particularly gracious with
their time and talents and in doing so
I'm enhanced the Columbia community at
this time while all those students who
receive departmental awards were
selected as senior marshals or were
honored at the king's crown leadership
awards dinner or other celebrations
please stand and be recognized for your
leadership it is now my pleasure to
present the final Ward's given on behalf
of the food Foundation School of
Engineering and Applied Science the
School of Engineering and Applied
Science scholar athlete award is
presented by the dean's office to the
graduating senior who has distinguished
himself or herself as a varsity athlete
and scholar this year the award is given
to Sarah Yee
the George Vinson when Dell memorial
medal was established in 1924 by friends
in the alumni and faculty of the late
Professor George Vinson window to honor
and perpetuate his memory
each department nominates one student
and the awardees are selected by vote of
the senior class this year the award is
given to Austin browser
the School of Engineering and Applied
Science Student Activities award is
presented to the undergraduate degree
candidate who by Bert who by virtue of
his or her willingness energy and
leadership has significantly contributed
to the co-curricular life of the school
this year I'm happy to present the award
to Heather League
the measure of the undergraduate
experience can be found not only in the
academics but in the service and
acceptance that one extends to others
has such campus life leadership awards
are given to those students whose
participation and undergraduate campus
life has enhanced a very spirit of
student life and created a purposeful
caring and celebratory community at
large the recipients of this award have
been successful in their endeavors to
create a more understanding and
accepting environment that preserves the
ideals and heritage of Columbia the 2010
recipients are Francis Jeffrey Coker
Sherwin Shara ray and Jack Yuen
the Constantino Colombo outstanding
leadership service award is presented to
an engineering student who has
demonstrated outstanding leadership and
service while working with a broad base
of undergraduate constituents and
administrators to enhance undergraduate
student life the award is presented in
honor of Chris Colombo who served for 16
years as the Dean of Student Affairs the
award this year is given to Whitney
Greene
if Charles candle metal was created by
alumni association and memory of Charles
Kendall class of 1911 civil engineering
whose tireless efforts were devoted to
helping undergraduate Engineers prepare
for the realities a professional life
after graduation their criteria for
selection are promoting the best
interests of Columbia and general
partaking in co-curricular activities
connected with the School of Engineering
and Applied Science actively
contributing to student and alumni
affairs and giving evidenced by specific
conduct or by his or her appreciation of
their traditions established by past and
present engineering alums and
recognition of the responsibilities that
hold this tradition and this year's
recipient is Whitney Greene
the Thomas pop Harrington medal is
awarded to that student in the
graduating class who best exemplifies
the qualities of character that preface
that professor Harrington exhibited
during his 40 years of teaching at the
School of Engineering from 1894 to 1935
the Harrington medal is made possible by
a generous and deeply appreciate a gift
by alumnus dr. my earn a Kohler this
year the medal is given to Stephanie
Quang
the Illig medal is the highest honor
awarded to an engineering graduate the
final prize is given to our ballot
Victorian the student with the highest
average the Illig medal was established
in 1898 by the quest from William C L ik
e m 1882 and is awarded by the faculty
to a member of the graduating class for
commendable proficiency in his or her
studies we would now like to
congratulate this year's recipient of
the Illig medal and your valedictorian
for the class of 2010
Seth Davey Davey tobits sorry
Thank You Dean swollen burger hello
everyone hi hello class of 2010 we are
in the presence today of many people
classmates faculty family friends who
for the past four years have provided us
all sorts of advice support knowledge
and those vitamin C supplements to keep
us from getting sick for all these
things all of them we're very fortunate
and give great thanks I've been told by
the powers that be that my speech should
not be longer than five minutes if I go
to ten someone will forcibly remove me
and if I can keep it to three the Dean
will give us another boat cruise free of
charge that might be a difficult task
with given the very alarming news
that I heard the other day I was
watching the Discovery Channel when I
heard it I imagine a number of you may
already be aware but the world is going
to end in December of 2012 something
about planetary alignments the Mayan
calendar Nostradamus floods earthquakes
and more I know I know I was shocked and
incredulous when I first heard it but
then I flipped over to that other
bastion of knowledge the History Channel
only to be confronted with the same
facts I did Google searches the same my
first reaction was to feel sorry for the
class of 2013
then I felt a heavy weight on my
shoulders no I was charged with send you
off into a world with only two years
left there's the obvious what better
time to take a chance and actually try
out all that clichd advice you've heard
before take time to smell the flowers
make sure your loved ones know how you
feel about them and pursue your dreams
with the vigor of someone who's noticed
there's not a minute to lose
but I wanted more so I searched far and
wide for the truly best advice I could
give you here's what I found
courtesy of Jerry Zucker don't buy
furniture with only two years left with
only two years left you're unlikely to
get enough use of it to make it
worthwhile more importantly it's likely
to only be an encumbrance to you tying
you down if you get too much we're at a
unique point in our lives not heavily
invested in furniture and no lifelong
career to lose all the value that we
have is in ourselves is the value of the
skills and knowledge and friendships we
have gained these past four years
through our Columbia education another
small bit of advice I found don't worry
too much about mistakes and failures
you're probably the only one so
incessantly focused on them anyway
compared to me you're golden
I just publicly predicted the end of the
world in two years based on the
Discovery Channel
seems like I've gone over my three
minutes sorry class of 2010 but no free
rides but I'm sure will do just fine
right in the words of Ghostface Killah
I've pinned all those other countries
this is Columbia
best of luck and congratulations
well I guess now we understand why he's
the valedictorian is a very difficult
act to follow now we know that we only
have two more years so make the best out
of it so for the ones that believe that
we still have more time let me tell you
that is a gives me a great pleasure this
afternoon to introduce to you a man who
I am are greatly the number of degrees
that he has from Columbia is by itself
reason enough to start the stang in all
for his achievements six degrees for
those of you who will be receiving your
PhD degree on Tuesday think about how
long it took you and then imagine going
on together MD a master in public health
and a doctorate in public health so you
can see there was a lot of time back
then
but today's class day speaker is not
someone who just accumulates academic
degrees he's a remarkable engineer who
sees his first profession as one the
halls the key to solving many of
societal problems and that is how our
school views each one of you he is the
personification of socially responsible
engineering applied science leader who
works for the betterment of the human
condition locally nationally and
globally
Paul brand roof was not only a student
at Columbia but also he was a member of
the faculty for 23 years
he joined Columbia igniting era file and
during his tenure he'll appointments as
professor and chair of Environmental
Health Sciences professor of medicine
professor of Earth animal mental
engineering and professor of
International and public affairs and is
currently a professor emeritus of the
University he assumed the post as Dean
of the School of Public Health at the
University of Illinois at Chicago in
2008 Dean brand roof has been the
recipient of many honors in occupational
and environmental medicine and sits on
the national board of directors of
Engineers Without Borders
he also has served as an adviser to the
World Health Organization the Mara
mental protection agency the
International Agency for research on
cancer and the Institute of Medicine of
the National Academy of Sciences among
many others the implant roofs research
is truly pan disciplinary as he spans
genetics human population studies
epidemiology molecular biology
environmental health and other
specialities to examine the relationship
between exposure to occupational and
mental car signals as they relate to
genetics and cancer all the while
considering the ethical issues that
surround them we are pleased that he is
able to be here today as your class day
speaker please join me in welcoming Paul
Brown drove the Quinn sensational
Columbia nearing Applied Science leader
well thank you very much for those mug
but most kind and gracious introduction
you make me sound a heck of a lot better
than I am in real life most people think
I just couldn't get out of school I
guess I'd like to begin by adding my
congratulations to the family faculty
guests friends and of course the
graduating class of 2010 I'd also like
to thank the University the school and
the Dean for offering me this
opportunity to address you today
now I'm sure despite that introduction
that there might be some of you who are
saying to yourself what does this guy
have to tell me about engineering well I
may have appeared to have traveled quite
away quite a long way since I last sat
in the chairs that you occupy today but
in truth I still use much of what I
learned here in engineering in my work
almost every day that's because much of
the improvement in the health of the
public has been achieved and is still
being achieved through engineering
solutions if you consider the large
improvements in morbidity mortality in
this country over the last 150 years
they were not principally due to new
medicines safer surgery or even vaccines
although I would note that engineers
contributed to all of those also but
rather they were due to the provision of
safe water sanitation cleaner energy
sources better transportation better
housing all very much engineering
solutions as a matter of fact one of the
prime movers behind the organized public
health movement in this country was a
graduate of the Columbia of Columbia
engineering he was an 1899 PhD graduate
from what was then the Henry Crown
School of Mines here at Columbia and his
name was George Soper his work on the
typhoid mary epidemic in New York in New
York City in 1907 was the primary
catalyst for the development of a new
discipline called Public Health which
attempted to combine engineering and
medicine and which eventually led to the
founding of the three first three
schools of Public Health at Harvard
Hopkins and Columbia so I think you can
see that engineering and Public Health
have a long shared history and are
actually intimately connected in that
both disciplines work to build a better
world in public health we vote we focus
on that better world as being a
healthier world on my own personal
journey from engineering to public
health as the Dean has alluded
I did manage to accumulate a lot of
degrees and one of the corollaries of
having done that as well as being a
faculty member for so many years is that
I have had the chance to hear dozens and
dozens of caste and commencement
speakers over the years and I thought
that this would surely be of assistance
as I prepared to address you today oddly
though thinking back over all those
speakers all that I came to mind
was that they seem to speak too long and
there was nothing in particular like
remember that they said this of course
turned out to be very reassuring to me
because I thought I can do that easily I
can drone on endlessly and say things
nobody will ever recall and I have years
of students behind me who would have
tested that readily but as the day grew
closer I found myself thinking a bit
more ambitiously
and keeping in mind that one of the
greatest speeches of all times Lincoln's
Gettysburg Address it was only two and a
half minutes long I decided it's time to
break with tradition I'm actually gonna
be brief and try to say something
memorable and I'm sure right I'm sure
you'll be thankful for the former if not
the latter although I warn you despite
the beard I'm no Abe Lincoln so settle
in since this is an institution of
higher learning one of the great
institutions of higher learning I want
to say something about higher education
in particular in general and engineering
education in particular and the
overarching theme that I would like you
to consider with me over the next few
minutes is engineering as a profession
and the engineer as an agent of social
justice something you probably have not
thought of before although maybe you
have so let me start with a quote from
someone who could be brief but memorable
Albert Einstein said the world we have
made as a result of the level of
thinking we have done thus far creates
problems we cannot solve at the same
level of thinking at which we created
them I'm gonna repeat that the world we
have made as a result of the level of
thinking we have done thus far
creates problems we cannot solve at the
same level of thinking we have created
which created them you have all spent
years acquiring a level of thinking
about engineering and science that
operates on a sending levels of
understanding you are all well-versed in
the generation collection of data the
analysis of data to create information
and the synthesis of information to
produce knowledge
but the new level thinking needed
requires more than knowledge although I
might usually be reluctant to quote
somebody like Donald Rumsfeld on the
subject of knowledge and it occurs to me
that many of you may not know even who
Donald Rumsfeld is but there is
something that your what he once said he
categorized knowledge as the known
knowns that's the things that we know
that we know we have that we have the
question and we know the answer the
known unknowns the things that we know
we don't know we have the question but
we don't yet know the answer and the
unknown unknowns the things that we
don't know that we don't know in fact we
don't even have the question something
to think about and that's where I I
robbed E's mother comes in who's that
well this name I hope may be familiar to
you aya Rabi was actually a Nobel
prize-winning physicist at Columbia he
worked over there and few been for many
years and when he was asked how come he
was able to do such groundbreaking work
to win the prize as a good Jewish boy he
said it was all deuter's mother mother's
pay attention every day after school he
would sit down over milk and cookies
with his mother and talk and the key
thing that she asked him was not whether
he got a good grade on the tests or if
he answered everything correctly but
rather did he ask any good questions so
what's that good question that will
drive us to the requisite new level of
thinking about engineering I think it's
what makes a wise engineer we must
strive for that level of thinking that
transforms the knowledge we have gained
into wisdom
after all we say that the highest degree
in higher education is the PhD the
doctor of philosophy from the Latin to
teach and the Greek a love of wisdom
wisdom requires that our evidence-based
knowledge becomes embedded in a
multi-dimensional ecosystem of
understanding with other levels of
thinking including a dimension of ethics
based values such as humanity humility
and honor among others in other words I
think knowledge requires an ethic to be
used wisely now I see some eyes glazing
over this is the point where those few
of you who are still listening to me
will be saying to yourself I don't care
about that ethic stuff if I'm
technically as proficient as I can be I
have done my job and my answer to that
is do you think of yourself as a
technician or a professional
Engineering is defined in one dictionary
as the application of science by which
matter and energy in nature are made
useful to people I'm sure you would all
agree that you should be as proficient
in applying science to transform matter
and energy but the rest of that
definition is equally important if not
more so namely in a way that is useful
to people the decision about what is
truly useful is a value judgement about
what is good and bad in other words it
requires incorporation of an ethic space
dimension as well as an evidence-based
dimension in your framework of
understanding the linear dimensional
framework of technical thing at which
I'm sure all of you Excel must be
embedded in a multi-dimensional
framework in which one of the other
orthogonal axes is ethics you want to
put in engineering terms the technical
engineer stops at the linear thinking
part but the professional engineer
operates in that larger framework we all
talk about an engineering profession and
in fact in every state in the Union you
can earn the legal credential
professional engineer but what does
being a professional mean one thing it
means is that not only have you been
privileged very privileged because you
here at Columbia to acquire specialized
skills and knowledge but also that you
recognize that that privilege comes with
responsibilities one of which is to use
the skill and knowledge wisely in a way
that is useful to people some of the
engineers of a prior generation who
designed and built the gas chambers for
the concentration camps made them
technically and frightening Lee very
efficient but it would be difficult to
say that they use their knowledge wisely
or a that they acted professionally the
challenge for this generation of
engineers is to accept your professional
responsibilities and act wisely
tempering your technical prowess with
ethics this is the new level of thinking
that is needed to solve the problems
created as a result of the level of
thinking we have done thus far this old
level of thinking has made a world that
is profoundly technologically efficient
in a way that is equally profoundly
unjust and unsustainable we have become
so technologically proficient in many
relating manner and energy in nature to
create and maintain our oversized
ecological footprint of our Western
lifestyle that we have in effect
condemned a significant fraction of this
generation to extreme poverty just as an
example consider that the average
ecological footprint of the typical
American you me and everyone here is
five times that of the world average if
all resources and ecosystem services
were distributed equally around the
globe and it is 15 times that of the
average ecological footprint of a
typical citizen of the third world and
the solution is not merely one of making
a current level of thinking about
technology available to the rest of the
world so that they can pursue our way of
life we have already exceeded the
Earth's carrying capacity with this
level of thinking and it would require
at least four to five planet Earth's to
do the same for the whole world's
population and as I recall planets good
planets are hard to find
which would only mean condemning future
generations to global ecological
catastrophe so we need a new level of
thinking that recognizes that
technological efficiency in the service
of the privileged few of this generation
is unwise because it is unjust to the
rest of humanity alive now and yet to be
born it's true that we must all change
our level of thinking but you as
professionals with your specialized
skills and knowledge have a
responsibility to be leaders in this you
should show the way you can show the way
you must show the way living up to your
professional responsibilities is not
just about knowing but about caring
because in the end people will not care
how much you know until they know how
much you care so there's a lot of hard
work ahead of you it's time is running
short
as you heard maybe two years maybe less
so you better get started that's why
today is part of a commencement it's
really just a start
I do have every confidence that you will
succeed because you don't only not know
what you don't know you don't know what
you can't do and that's good because you
can probably do just about anything but
I also think the Dean may have failed to
mention the bad news although you will
receiving your diploma soon you must
pass one final exam before you fully
deserve them
you didn't know that hmm the good news
is it's a take home exam you get to
grade it yourself and you have a
lifetime to complete it if in 40 or 50
years at the end of your professional
career you can look at yourself in the
mirror and truthfully say that you've
used your knowledge wisely to build a
better world for all then you will have
earned your degree so go build a better
world we're all counting on your
leadership your professionalism and your
wisdom thank you
so please join me in welcoming your
class president Heather Lee
president Bollinger Dean pena Mora
Provost Steel's Dean Sholem Berger dr.
Brandt ruff faculty family and friends
of the class of 2010 good afternoon and
thank you
your being here really shows the support
we have had on our journey to this point
Columbia engineering class of 2010
congratulations we're almost there but
not quite you just have to listen to my
speech
bask in some more congratulatory remarks
and walk across the stage to shake a few
hands and receive your class pin I find
that antipas anticipation makes
everything a lot better
select the anticipation build-up for
another few minutes my mom always told
me that what makes that my mom always
told me that manners are the most
important and that I should always give
thanks or do so let me take a moment to
thank the people who have helped us get
to this point Thank You professors for
challenging us without you the
neverending problem sets and the grades
that really put the C in sees many of us
do not have experienced that true
perseverance is Thank You Dean Tania
Maura for the C's crown ties and scarves
that most of us are wearing and the
amazing class dinner free clothing and
free meals are the way into most of our
hearts and I think it's safe to say that
you've been very successful this year
thank you caffeine for getting us
through the sleepless weeks and mud and
lastly thank you to all the parents in
the audience who helped pay for college
tuition
we couldn't have gone here without your
support your care packages and your
constant worrying and concern but look
we made it we're here and I know that
you were very proud of us
C's 2010 errs this may be the perfect
time to ask for next month's rent
so yes we made it but not without some
challenges in between which makes this
moment that much better
I could reminisce about all the
struggles led at Columbia and there were
plenty trust me but I'd much rather
focus on the positive the experiences I
have had with all of you here for the
last four years have been memorable and
so amazing I'll miss hanging out with
you on the steps when the weather is
nice and playing on the lawns for the
two weeks that they're open
I'll miss staying up during um I'll miss
staying up all night in mud 282 fighting
with a sting but taking heart in the
fact that our whole class is there too
I've learned so much during my time here
at Columbia I learned the difference
between a batch reactor and a CSTR
I learned how to program Turing machines
I learned how to hail a cab quickly
realizing that it's not actually like in
the movies where y el taxi unit just
shows up and stops for you
I learned that deeds are often more
important than words and I also learned
that there's a rivalry between NorCal
and SoCal the most important thing that
I've learned however is that what truly
makes an experience special and
meaningful are the people that are
involved our class sees 2010 has been
part of such an amazing things this year
we were the second class to be inducted
into the order of the engineer
officially making it a tradition that
were ethical and engineers we brought
back Columbia engineering merchandise to
the bookstore and we have bonded during
learner pubs senior nights lots of C's
2010 shirts and a ton of free food and
the fact that we're all in C's some may
say that among us are the next Einsteins
Newton's Curry's but I like to look at
it a little bit differently we will be
ourselves and we will be the first the
first Davey divets is the first gens the
first Andrade's the first leave we came
to Columbia to be individuals to offer
the world something special with our
education and our experiences scientists
may discover what already is but
engineers create what never was no
matter what Plato said oh look a CC
reference
no matter what industry we venture into
or subject we choose to study further we
will inevitably look about how things
can be improved and optimized or how
many things can be created we will be
the first even with our senior design
projects we have already done so much we
have designed a chair that aids the
elderly and disabled in dressing a
device for safely cutting high tension
cables a smart cervical dilator a
continuous positive airway pressure
machine to help babies in third world
countries breathe and so many others if
we've already accomplished all these
things as students imagine what we can
do without the added pressures of
problem sets tests and overall college
drama engineers help make the world a
better place and I'm excited to see what
you all have to offer someone once said
if opportunity doesn't knock build a
door and it shouldn't be a problem since
they're engineers and we build things
before I conclude my remarks I want to
thank my family is over there somewhere
thank you mom for talking to me every
day on the phone and pouring your
constant love and affection on me thank
you Dad for keeping me on track and
trusting me to do the best that I can do
and thank you to my brother Nathan for
always believing in me without fail even
when I don't I've loved my time here I
have loved my time here and I know the
main reason is because of all of you I
have been surrounded by such amazing
people during our senior class dinner I
told you that what truly sets us apart
is our camaraderie through our struggles
and our many successes we have come
together and grown as a class so I will
miss you all thank you for allowing me
to serve as your class president for the
last four years and now I will close as
I have always closed my class emails
over the four years with a little bit of
modification PS if you have questions
suggestions or just want to chat you can
email I am or find me in person I'll
answer you stat and if I don't know the
answer 100% I'll find a way to help you
to the farthest extent and as you go on
to wherever you will go make
sure you remember and make sure you
always know we will always be engineers
at the center of our core we will always
be C's 2010 errs can you ask for
anything more and lastly we will always
be able to call Colombia our home no
matter how much we deviate from
engineering travel or Rome we are
forever bonded by our education and our
experiences here so for our four years
together let's let out a cheer
congratulations Colombia engineering
class of 2010
Thank You Heather at this time each
graduate will be invited to the stage
for recognition dan Civello and Nicholas
Jennings both leaders in our alumni
community will present each member of
the class of 2010 with the school's
insignia on behalf of Columbia
engineering Alumni Association
please reframe your please refrain from
applause until all members of class have
returned to their seats
who's who's this
we make sure you're there the right way
Seth Davidovich Rodney Chang Heather
Janine Lee Charles bender Benjamin
McCaleb jr. Megan Teresa de been in
court
Ariel Lana Rhenish viola Fatima Austin
James browser stephanie hwang Shirin
David sure a here a Whitney green
Frances Shea Jeffrey Coker Sarah
Michelle ye Jack Lang Ewan Elizabeth
Pelton John Sean Penn and Quay
Christopher Tom ye Jeffrey Andrew
Rodriguez Daniel Marcus Garcia tat Hong
Wong Estella Gonzales Judith Rivas
Ishmael NATO Edward Lee Kim Jae Yoon
Chang Jeffrey Manuel Andre de xalapa van
de hora van Rijn Raul galati Darren
Christopher pagan Arista roshanda Hector
Glenfield Alexander Jarvis Julian O'Neil
Hector Janis Xavier
Aisha bonhomie David Daniel Adam ganjam
Daniel Eric Marco so Evan Roth Mikael
Nikifor
Jen Wang Jacob Todd Rose
Lochte Bella Simone Anna hope Margaret
polenin Jefferson open okra COO Batum
Bay and Doran Ernest quake ooh sorry
Samuel doot doo na Khushi Khalid
Terrence David Roxanne Roxanna do nod
Cindy Lynn true nicole scott rome Andre
Carly Eileen Becker Michael Christopher
seaman John Murphy to show Joe Valerie
go no deep Krishna shritha sivadas Union
Williams Roebuck Todd quad Volvo Khadija
ransom
Nelson Jose and do gar Tasha can do all
Grace who Jung Lee Janet Lee Jennifer
Chen
picanha curiata Victoria Lynn Jeannine
sang Michael was check sick Marc Anthony
fitori Xiao Zhang Cheng Zhi on Lu Jenny
hue when qu on Brian Ross albert daniel
says baron
Carol Lee Vincent Wang diana and jiang
grace she Henry Lee Alex Rudin
Jeffrey Cho Andrew lo Zeus whoo
Eric chasing tang jessica Lee Lewis
Alvin 10 Jessica April Joe Emily Ying
Lau Jacqueline on Mason young Benjamin
Lee Eugene Boone
Amanda Zhi Yoon yup
Jesse Chen alexander marshal Brenton
tani Kia Olin auskey sophronia you
lindsey marie turner hannah elizabeth
more Lawrence Chang Alanna favor Brian
Adam Hashima Stanley German Anthony liao
Suho Choi
Jorge Alejandro Garcia Sara Pilar Kramer
Robert jokubas Marin Kovich Jonathan
Aaron Levie Derek Daniel Fajardo Alan
Joseph Eleniak iris a Kimberly and
Rodrigo
Michael Giordano Vikram Mohan Mary Norah
Dixon Connor
Asen Helen boseok Omer air Kevon Mackey
Youssef JD Williams Xue Shao Yong Li you
Brianne Liu Christopher touchin David
Harrison Megan Taniya Truong Cody Jenn
Simon Thomas Thompson Michael Shawn
Tracy Erika Sun Hong Hong Zachary
Ballard Yan Bing Trey Shandling vu Seung
Jun hyung Union Cho Sun Yong Quan chuan
wan Park jeong-ho Jason Lee Jung Geun an
Daniel Fernando Falcone Marv AJ langu
now James Yugi Oh Jung mean watching
Tian luan grace Chen
Vivien Wang Robert James Frawley the
third
Lauren and Lamora Frank
Alvaro Corinne Kotoko Fukuyama Megan
Christine Anderson Jonathan Cahn Rebecca
when shooting Victor lang Michael OH
Matthew Lee Edward you Adam bruising
over Julian Taylor a mandolin Urich
Jennifer Jen Wang Andrea Nicole
Castaneda Daniel Arturo Miranda
Kevin Jacob urakami Samuel Lee Kelly
Chen Henry Wayne chalk Lau Stanley Chen
Christina Katherine Fishman Islam bosun
shocky
shareer ashada Meyer Michael Stephen
Lazar Ian Thompson Peters George Paul
Zhou deceive Olivetti Michael Court ray
Connie Chang Margaret montine Wang
Drago's Vallecano Joseph Marcos Yusef
Peter J Traverso Raji Prasad Shah
Richard Samson Samrat Bhattacharya Erin
Elizabeth crafts Christopher men cry
ingrian David Steiner Chimel Nicholas
Gabriel Borenstein Philip Michelle
pussies
Anthony Matthew Jim
Kenneth Alexandra Rivera
Omar Dilip Patel Albert Chen Daniel
Jacob fain Steen Boris Grinspoon Anatole
vac matterr Alison Ray Show Nick
Benjamin Harun waters in Meeker McKenley
Kyle West Cobb ningn lung James John
Garofalo Derek Brian Hernandez
Guillermo Vinicius at a house show
Shandong Kenneth John Vanderpool Yin Joe
Michael John Cabral Steven Michael Perry
John Roland della morte Alan Phillip
lamer Mike Lee George Anthony Cole
Richards Aaron Samuel Hochberg Sharon
Wong Zhao
Alicia Jacqueline Chen Xuan yang Frank
Morris Dean graph Philippe custodian
Ricardo Gonzalez Jeffrey Kevin Sibbald
Andrew Jennings Staedtler Alexander
Fernando Chang Kenneth Cole Albert
Hawaii Li Ian fields Van Sant's Raphael
James levy Chris Khanna
Chirag managing Patel Philip
Reince Neider Kristin Loveland Alexandre
Schwartz right Philip Surya
Anderson brian wei pan children ho
Shella marie baki
ro Joon oppa dia Prasant Vargas
Ravi Varkey choco beneath Kocherlakota
mark sue Gregory
Yefremov shafy hawk Thomas Edison slant
/ chris linn Vivian chan Everard Alfred
Belen
lindsey marie snuggles Sabir son dear
Trista anouk - Rita Pavel toluse
whoa gee Patrick Steven Hesse Dave Anand
Sarah sook sook Deo Ephraim Sala hanok
you chuck Ariel Schwartz daniel ben de
Abid David Adom Englehart John currence
own Heymann Lee Daniel Martin Siebert
Tucker Roy Gilman bjorn Peter pannu
Anderson Lisa Michele Chamberland
Khalil P Glenn Adam Theodore steed Mario
Agustin Avila Robert Bennett's
myung-hoon Han Michael yuan wang
Benjamin Shen holy a Inca Ambrose GG
Jamie Lee
Jennifer Singh ting Mui shreya
khadiyah Claire Michelle Papa well
Jonathan Schafer bell gee cello Wong
Stewart James Parton Arnold in dong Park
Michael Gregory glass
Sudeep Muniz Hank
McVicar Geoffrey will though eh phone
Rowan dare Alberto Torres Kevin James
Luke Diana Lima Alexander Rodney key
Pradeep Bandaru Rashad Bose Roy Michelle
Gosha Maddox key David for Flair ledge
Eugene yo Carolyn and pop well Adrian
Daniel him ovitch Marilyn sue Meza
Giuliani Fernandez Benjamin isert
Mountain Steven Hale jr. Christopher wen
han wang Sahar Hasan Danielle Adele Pheo
Benjamin Ross Arnold Rick Austin patita
Shari Weinstock Ansel John Ryan with all
Daniel Joseph Kennedy k har-har inshaa
Rohan Honda Wayne mark simonetti Demetri
Keselowski Victoria Golan Katherine
Rachel condom Ling Singh Alice chain
Keith Chen Matthew Simmons sinchon Ava
jalisa Romina Luna Amy Maria Sanchez
Amy Janel narf Monica Sonia Josie Emma
Kathryn Cramer Kimberly and Lambrecht
Janelle nope
Nicole Hyslop David James Murphy the
fourth - ooh Ethan Lucas
Chung David Q it mezco jug Z Aaron Shalu
Corps Han Shi / Robert Peter Logan a
Mitra dance Gupta Benjamin August Mel
nor Melanie Sarah silver Elaine Maria
silver Zhang Liu Lee Jung Seng Chris Lim
Leon Wang CERN Shimbun China pitch
pitcher precede me Boone
Gian Lisa young Lauren Courtney park
david mao lan yu alexis King Machuca in
neatly Perry totin yin timothy james
campbell walker Blackwell plash Lillian
alfred guitry Madeline Elise lope Minh
Harrison Kuno Yamamoto
Joey arimin Roland Lee Allen Shalem bat
or chase Hansel
Daniel Samuel hurts now presenting the
Master of Science degree candidates Alan
mark read a Vince key Jason ciao
Andrew Chen Lily win Changu prashanta
Dunston Kelly chin
Carlos Manuel Gonzalez Peter Chung
Alexander Sebastian boat elite ski
Gretchen
Audrey Meyer UVO Natan Adam Stewart
Kasim Eric Kevin Michael Williams Combes
I spelt things are che ma Stephen M
Leung Jim ty Patrick Michael Alexander
men GU sook on shalosh Saroja
Sean Co shoe bro Dae young Ling Wang Jun
Zhang Jia hooning day Xu yang she Valley
shall boy ye shed green Z Zhang
Christopher Wang
I'm kit Mehta socket go L pry win
boo Tata Pollack bed
Vinod Kumar Ivanov Sharma unkicked Rocca
ela Agarwal
why leave been Lu Bo Zhang David
Harrison hi Wang seaman Xiao Fang Wei
Zhang seaming son Ken her Co Ichiro
mustard naka yuan wang David bone dotty
Alexander Digby Williams Edward Peter
both sing a paella Adi DJ Demi as je
Timoteo
Oh Femi for what a see bill teleport LOD
Pat Isabel Murray Sanson olivier de la
plaine bow here lay plain bow
Cheyenne Schriever son Ryan Bonaparte
Cheung Chen Jason shredder
Milko Paulo Hilda goner Young's daughter
Ellen schlossberg Jasmine see will Lewis
bridges ruse at any issue a Luca RS OA
Jonathan David Thompson
hi I'm Cohen Laura Liberty Lauren Bashar
Caroline Ducharme Audrey Stoltz baptise
Kenichi Adrian clearin Pierre Bilotti
Thomas Edward Ferguson jawad Abbate
pratik Bhatia Rashi AJ Garg night eek
Ramesh sangani Yan Yan syrup are Lima
people Vasili oz cameras
Ali I mean masseur Alejandro Nara no
Omar Elba Serie B la vida l-mawla
Karim Shuaib Ermac kuzu mucho Rosen is a
rotten son
Dimitri's androulakis Emanuel Ax vaguely
knows
constantinos a ski to Palace Thomas
Franza khakis Anastasios Americas Olga
Marco Inaki Antonio's key periodic geo
geo surgeries Vasily Oz Papa Christo's
fouling Wang Shang hailey
she Halle ow then you Tao Shang Hong
Kong Jiali
Shin Dong Jo Shin Wong Eleni mavrodi D
AB enough
Sharon Tanya Abu Nazir Nicholas Harry
Bihar Assam da tunak tun Rio ver Shecky
coach Agha here Christian
Felipe boost Tebow sudden Marian delag
kala toughie
LOD Co crystal not sure James Chris
poker Eduardo Vaman odd VIN burg emini
ADA Curran Semra trommel Lynn epidural
boa tongue Supriya cooked a cheat d
kappa Dora Ruchika
agrawal Maria Isabella
kazoo Sally Adrian leaf ranked upon 2 le
du musst EA Michael autumn
Benjamin belly
Kareem Tama resist mark jm4x
pierre-joseph Martin bourgeois Jose
Carlos Edo Pilar Gonzalez Marat dog rue
Lee su Flynn mark Fernandez lamken
Richie Chan Harry Wong Peter Lou
Federico Bella rowdy Anna Alena baby
you've dimmer art Alessandra been a
maroon-colored come sue Dean Charles de
frame Avila Bertrand Bastion Siva
Shankar Palma Seany daddy fresh Olufsen
hehe whoo
Saturn Larry wall
moo-coo Agarwal Shyam sundar asan Nilesh
column car pretty clear Matthew
Lorant Pfizer Maxim Lagarde Jeffrey
furball Pierre de Grey yeah I'm putting
on the top I put them on the bottom okay
Nicholas Tia Julian GAO's e Martin
Lehmann which Hank MOT Matthew 10 News
Jennifer zisman Arielle I gained Kenneth
Roederer Justin Daniel Stein Haus soo
knock hung in Keiichi I not go ABI Sola
alle da boo
I'll assume Bo Lukic a - on a ride hi
can bet a I think they went they already
went across the stage
Suzanne you win
Amy Marie dagger ooh
Disha sha William David after the third
been sack Simon James
she's kayo ho Satsuma rate that tong li
jie zhao ting zoo cur
Lin Lin song Stefan is effing off
cephalic off Pedro Felipe lega Paul best
Matthew Diaz Matthew rano Widow
Myron chin down Christopher John rap
holy Matteo chesco yin-yang louisia who
Gary
kei-chan Benjamin Craig Isham Jordan
Lorenz Mendell
Michael Michael real carrying a D
Christian D P so saputra poor no mo
Putra cipta where I look you tomorrow
Victoria chin Shanta new Basu Iqbal
bonanni Hamza ox EB AB the Nestor is a
hurry
Osama flat tree dress Baloo Bharat
Ramachandran
Michael Khalil Matthew Brian Bouchard
David Coulter Genk rah
Nicole marine Puma Riga Halle and
bunting Aaron David Kaplan manager sing
at par Rostow g.j Leverett Nicholas
Edward mulaskey I am by her mean Lu
Cheng shank you
Tang Mateo Montes see pre air Francesco
Paolo Mara
Alessandro Martucci Julian Makarov
franceska check irini Luciana box amo
Matteo Farooqi Stefano Branca
Faiza Khan Khattak me shots
Ravindra Shah cost show in Lin hot car
Aaron Clarence
Fernandez Scott Joseph Gaiden Brian K
Scott Brian Michael bull theis it's
Miguel Gomez Sharif Oh Islam Chowdhury
Ryan Jansen Adam Kasper zyk Jaclyn Jacob
Webster Daniel Ross the third Daniel
Neal Lewis to windra Laurel car Pranav
Garg
Shuji Agora John Sebastian a j NJ
ibrahim EULA ka hai mere oz bag Burke
beer on on Rick K toca Lugo blue rock
bass Kurt
Barack okay Aaron tecnine Shyam Sanna
darf don't walk moon jong-min Lim Jong
Kook Kim Rashard Aceveda
Kimberly Petersen Vinay Kumar batu putih
Sreenivas
Ron Sumeet Jindal Sherrod was Karen
Muhammad Amir Akhtar you jean-carlo
belong Ranjha my or loda Lakshmi nah dig
and you need Dylan and cush oil Jurgen
Shi sha Patrick Thomas brew ik Luke bear
J Bret Alexander Benowitz
Adam Lewis inner McCool Ethan Lackey
Matthew Jake debo Sloane
Pablo author
Preetam munos Jae ho Chung funny near ah
T Chintan go he'll sue has Prakash Nia
Kotani Priam body de Schumacher Vamsi
Nala nanu and Nikhil Ramesh
she house I Shin Yao Lin Cynthia mingfu
Kong Amandine Florence dis Lane go da
Furnham on Zachary Renee Kenneth
Colin J mcLaughlin Gabriel acha Magda
galley Karthik sassy Hilo seed or kapha
Adarsh Aravalli Venkatesh
Ravi Kiran her seat say a Ravindra Babu
Ganapathy but Adam a regretful Oscar
Enrique Morales Ming Qiong Wu ji Chang
Kwon Jin Jong Lee thn how aiming Amy Yin
Yi Chan ching ching chang shreekant nice
shot nothin Ramachandran Shakir Hurst in
ash Park Anoosh Dasha Polly Rupa Kahaluu
hoody ashwa narasimhan Moses Vaughn was
seem con ella he Joanne Provencher Alina
Cho player ping Han see
shark Wan Chu Cao Lu Hao Henry mu mu
Cheng Liu Paul bohyun shim Daniel M
Freedman Nicholas Allen lijinsky
soos car compare Amal Van Diemen Roy
Landon Karthik Maruchan ramen Sammy the
room Joe sing so ha
Chen Jian Chen XI Hong Shi raffia
Greenbaum Arthur Shiraz Siddiqui grace
honorable tell Robert Martin Toofer Zi
Feng Huang Jing Wu Chi in Cho
Shao Yin Wong so Han yung Bao J son
Austin Lee Jimmy Lee
Paul s gray wall Wayne Liu Shu Francis a
Smith Hari Prasad pasola Abhishek Butler
Amit Pandey aswani Agarwal Anoosh Gupta
kvish a coupla Masud Ali Mahdi any trend
Eloisa era kin ja yeah - young Nicholas
Jin Fong own then how turn Nitin Haller
ceruse Gaurav dawning Yong ping Joe
Sally do
e Li Wei Chen lung Cheung sha Huang
saran poet Erin on Regina Chi Chile
gives me a great pleasure to present the
professional degrees dong who Lee your
Shahida Okayama Perry Victor Lee gives
me a great pleasure to present the
engineering science doctorate Yao Li si
you adore Lawrence will key the second
Matthew Basinger
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the class of 2010
immediately following the conclusion of
the ceremony we invite you to join us
it's a reception over in Hamilton lawn
and congratulate our graduates and we
ask that you remain in your seats until
the recessional has concluded we will
close the class day exercises with
singing of Stan Columbia and roar lion
roar by Columbia students and we welcome
you to sing along the lyrics are in the
back of your program
her name
welcome our newest alumni class of 2010
you